that Paul Whalen guy ain't the only spy
in Russia just like we got Russian spies
here right now there's some [ __ ]
Russian assigned to this podcast [ __ ]
you know what I mean but there is like
we're an influential [ __ ] podcast
maybe he's a cool guy how do we know
he's a cop he's a cuck how could he not
be a cuck what if we bring him over to
our side
what if he's listening he's like man
these guys are kind of cool yeah what's
up they're good guys
yeah we just pull him over
um
the real army yeah that he's probably a
patron do we have we have to have at
least one Russian spot that listens at
least there's probably many spies I
think there's a lot of spies to listen
yeah
no he's buying this room now we have a
few Chinese spice you think so yeah how
do you know because it's me getting gay
oh [ __ ] wait a minute and there has to
be spies that listen just because they
need someone to listen to yeah like
there are spies that have nothing to do
with America but they are spies like
right now there's a spy listening to
this and like he's a little bit
concerned what the [ __ ] they're talking
about me like he could be in Istanbul
what if you are like there's a spot
right now it's like how do they know him
in Istanbul dude there's some Japanese
dude just carrying himself because we
found out that he's a spine but we have
no no clue that you're actually a spy we
don't know we do know you know what I
mean if miles isn't on my [ __ ] single
for everything I swear to god
making sure that was a great wink all
I'm trying to say is we have spies that
listen to this podcast yeah we might
have Warlords to listen to this podcast
whoa Coney you think Tony's listening I
don't know what Cody's up to
but they're guaranteed there's at least
one warlord yeah yeah
what do you think Warlords do when they
wake up in the morning you have a cup of
ah they don't want to hear us they want
to hear like people that motivate them
to kill and do bad [ __ ] maybe they kill
so much they just want a challenge
yeah
no I think that they also want to break
for more yeah you don't think they come
back no kick their feet up yeah a little
bloody blood on their shoes just listen
to some pod you don't think that that's
possible
impossible
impossible
now I feel like you know a [ __ ] woman
not too hot on the trail right now bro
like come on bro I'm talking to my guy
[ __ ] warlord that listens to the
goddamn pot did you get them pants from
the Taliban tell us the Taliban I'm
gonna be good in Morocco I'll be so good
bro I'll be so good of her I don't know
if you're gonna be good in Morocco not
after this are you Taliban no of course
not be honest bro of course not I might
be the Spy yo Al might be the spot I was
gonna spy energy I would be the worst
[ __ ] spot because one of the best
four country and now yeah but I'm for me
but I'm also
that would be the best double agent ever
yeah but to himself yeah yeah it'd be
perfect
okay wow wow
you would be an absolutely horrible spy
or the best I don't know yeah I think
you would be a worse spy I'll be honest
as long as I could tell someone you just
need to give me something I could gossip
to immediately yeah the podcast exactly
yeah no that's what if I don't have the
podcast you got to give me something I
could call back home and I can tell you
the cool [ __ ] alert yo yo yo who ain't
got cancer but someone's gonna attack
people think he's on the phone that's my
point someone's gonna tap your line come
on you don't know how to use other
technology I'll use it I'll do this one
right here oh I got a picture
a little New York Times article don't
want it whatever I don't know how to get
my point I think you'd be a bad spot
dude no no think about it the
government's thought about Contracting
you for the record I want you to know
that I mean it's the perfect cover you
buy emails can we you got an email I
didn't get emailed I didn't get an email
directly was that a phone call WhatsApp
WhatsApp the CIA mostly does WhatsApp
hold on you told me
what's going on
for people listening
we're talking about Andrew being a
secret agent don't you think I would be
a good spy here talk on that mic right
there and then you can remain your
anonymity
okay don't you think I would be a good
spy as long as I could gossip to one
specific person or the country as long
as I had someone to tell the secret name
of his wife gossip to the whole country
no no yeah yeah exactly
I just need to share cool information
with people that's all I'm saying right
so if I could tell if I could tell you
if I could tell my guy at the CIA as
long as there's somebody that I could
hey I found this cool thing out there's
gonna be a war in Ukraine that's what a
spy does eventually right everyone
everything
all at once all right I'm gonna tell
them some cool [ __ ] I learned exactly
yeah exactly yeah you know if uh dates
are so popular and whatever
you know what I mean like I'll exchange
cool fun information but I'm not gonna
be I'm not gonna just blabber I'm not a
blabbermouth
I have to to afford this lifestyle
get paid probably a thousands I'm not
the same as you make now ain't no way
bro do you think they pay Spots I'm not
kidding no I guess I'm saying you're not
willing to take that pay cut in an
exchange out of bitterness you're just
gonna gossip everything
all right maybe I wouldn't be the Best
Buy in the entire world salary of a CIA
spot ranges from 21 000 to 500 000. who
the [ __ ] is making twenty one thousand
so if you can't touch the 21 000 bye bro
what are you doing
there's no security clearance for 21 000
parts
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
bro I'm not gonna spy
but you this is the perfect front right
comedian travels around the world doing
shows but also listening oh yeah as long
as it's International I thought that
about him me yeah I'm not a spider
French Canadian all this extra [ __ ] a
little gay like is I don't have enough
leaders wanted to be in the CIA do you
remember that nah it was a secret
service secret service and then Trump
ran and I was like yeah I'm good that
was the reason no you [ __ ] it up
you know I was in L.A we were going to
all-star weekend and y'all were smoking
weed and then I was like nah I can't I'm
trying to be in secret service and
Andrew's like you sure and he's like all
right give me the week
[Laughter]
the whole deal
um I don't know nothing nothing really
nothing really else I mean it just does
feel a little bit of an unfair trade but
maybe I wasn't motivated as much by like
what Brittany did for basketball
for female basketball because there are
certain
there are certain NBA players where I'm
like like if Steph Curry was locked up
in Russia
traded up he person of death whatever
change the game you can't shoot like
Steph yeah I look at that Victor about
guy right in his face you cannot shoot
like Steph
I trade for merchant of War so I think I
just wasn't influenced Enough by
Brittany what do you think wins
one-on-one Victor bout or Brittany
Greiner
scissoring competition no no basketball
first to seven
I think Victor
still at 55 probably nah he's locked
away for a while there's a lot no way
all you do is play basketball when
you're locked up oh they get nice do you
think he'd been doing something
cool
too he's playing Bully ball that jail
[ __ ] like oh he's bought it there's
no way there's no way also do you see
the way Brittany was walking at when she
was going to the like at the uh how
crazy is the trade president the trade
was great did you see it no bro oh yeah
but also you got to look at Britney's
walk
bro the actual like video of them
trading I didn't think was going to be
like that I thought it was going to be
like more professional and like oh
that's just like the movies bro and they
got to go to neutral territory where did
they do it because I saw a [ __ ]
dress like me kind of right now there
was a guy with the the white I think it
was the UA UAE somewhere in the Middle
East yeah
mm-hmm but yeah they just pulled up
swapped them I couldn't believe it I
like blew my mind that that's how that's
how they do it